und in Berlin begrüße ich Hans-Georg
Maaßen guten Abend guten Abend werden
Sie aus der CDU austreten
bisher weiß ich nur aus den Medien dass
man gerne möchte dass ich bis Sonntag 12
Uhr eine Erklärung abgebe ich war vorher
noch mal bei meinem Postfach bis jetzt
habe ich noch keinen Schreiben der CDU
bekommen das ist das Mindeste was ich
eigentlich erwarten kann dass man mich
persönlich oder schriftlich durch ein
Schriftsatz darüber informiert was man
gerne von mir möchte wenn ich es bekomme
werde ich prüfen und mich dann
gegebenenfalls äußern nur haben sie es
ja ausführlich überall gehört und auch
davon gelesen und wissen wir dass
derzeit die Post gelegentlich streikt
vielleicht liegt sie auch simpel einfach
nur daran aber sie haben natürlich ein
bisschen Zeit gewonnen darüber
nachzudenken wie haben Sie denn darüber
nachgedacht
nun bisher höre ich einfach nur
Behauptungen auch von dem Professor juhn
vorhin wurde gesagt
verschwörungstheoretische oder
oder rechte Äußerung hätte ich getätigt
keinerlei Belege und ich muss auch sagen
die Vorwürfe die ich auch so höre auch
sie haben vorhin aus dem Beschluss des
bundespräsidiums ein Auszug genannt das
sind pauschale Verunglimpfung die mit
nichts zu belegen sind und ich wachte
auf diese Belege die mir mit dem
Schriftsatz sicherlich übersandt werden
und für die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
noch mal in Erinnerung zu rufen sie
waren von 2012 bis 2018 Präsident des
Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz sie
mussten dann den Posten räumen nachdem
sie rechtsextreme Ausschreitungen in
Chemnitz in Zweifel gezogen hatten 2021
schalteten sie bei der Bundestagswahl
als CDU Direktkandidat in Thüringen wie
viele Freunde haben sie noch in der CDU
dadurch muss sie in einem Punkt
korrigieren ich habe niemals richtig
extremistisch Ausschreitungen Chemnitz
sind Zweifel gezogen dies gab ich habe
im Zweifel gezogen dass es dort
hetzjagdten gab es gab keine Hetzjagd in
Chemnitz den Beweis ist bisher auch ja
sind auch die Medien schuldig geblieben
es gab keine Hetzjagden ich habe Freunde
in der CDU und ich gehe davon aus dass
ein sehr sehr viele heute hat man mir
wieder von der Werte Union mitgeteilt
wir haben wieder neu Eintritte in die
werteunion im dreistelligen Bereich
innerhalb eines Tages ich glaube das was
in den letzten Tagen von der Partei mit
mir gemacht wird hilft der Werte Union
sehr und vor dem Hintergrund kann ich
auch dankbar sein der Berliner Kreis der
CDU mit der Spitze von Silvia Pantel
steht an meiner Seite das ist der Kreis
der konservativen Funktionsträger und
Mandatsträger der CDU und natürlich der
mein Wahlkreis in dem ich kandidiert in
Südthüringen steht auch an meiner Seite
und ich gehe davon aus dass sehr sehr
viele
Partei Mitglieder einfache Partei
Mitglieder meine Auffassung teilen denn
es besteht ein Unterschied zwischen der
Funktionärsebene und der Mitglieder
Ebene also zu den Hetzjagden in Chemnitz
sag ich mal als Journalist in Klammern
Anmerkung der Redaktion das ist darüber
natürlich unterschiedliche Ansichten
gibt wie es ja auch bei den anderen
Dingen ist bei Zitaten die von ihnen
überliefert sind lassen sie uns
zurückkommen zu den Vorgängen dieser
Woche CDU-Chef Merz er gehört ja nun
offenbar nicht zu ihren Freunden er sagt
er wolle sozusagen mit seinem Vorgehen
Schaden von der Partei abwenden und ja
er attestiert ihnen offenkundig sei
ihnen nicht am Wohl der CDU gelegen sie
würden laufend gegen die Grundsätze und
die Ordnung der Partei verstoßen wie
reagieren sie auf diesen Vorwurf des
immerhin Parteivorsitzenden
zum einen muss ich sagen das sind auch
wieder pauschale Anwürfe ich erwarte
dass das unterlegt wird mit Belegen in
welchem Punkt habe ich wie der CDU
geschadet und in welchem Punkt habe ich
mich wie geäußert was jedenfalls mit der
Linie der CDU nicht den Einklang steht
an der Stelle bitte schön einen Beleg
der
antisemitismusbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung Felix Klein der wirft
ihnen eine Relativierung des Holocaust
vor Grund sei ein Tweet vom 13 Januar
indem sie behaupten die treibenden
Kräfte im politischen medialen Raum
hätten als Stoßrichtung eine
eliminatorischen Rassismus gegen Weiße
und den brennenden Wunsch dass
Deutschland Zitat verrecken möge
treibende Kräfte in Politik und Medien
wollten also die weißen vernichten wie
kommen sie auf solche Aussagen
ich komme auf diese Aussagen wenn sie es
im Zusammenhang sehen und wenn sie es
auch sehen worauf ich mich beziehe ich
beziehe mich auf die critical Race Serie
und auf Aussagen eines Axel Steyr der
selbst ernannte Seenotretter ist nach
dieser Theorie sollen Weißbrote das
heißt also weiße Menschen sollen
aussterben und die Migranten werden nach
Deutschland geholt damit die weißen
Aussterben das kann man alles nachlesen
und ich mache den Vorwurf dass dies
rassistisch ist der Begriff
illuminatorischer Rassismus hat nicht zu
tun mit einer Vereinfachung für eine
einer Reduzierung des des historischen
Holocaust steht in keinem Zusammenhang
weil dieser Begriff auch von anderer
Seite verwendet wird z.B von der Linken
amadeo Antonio Stiftung ganz im
Gegenteil kann man sagen was ich hier
gemacht habe ist ein Begriff der
politischen Linken zu übernehmen und den
Vorwurf zu machen das von politischen
links grüner Seite hier ein Rassismus
betrieben wird und ich erwachte und
verlange gerade von meiner Partei dass
man sich mit diesem Vorwurf des
Rassismus auf linksgrüner Seite
auseinandersetzt aber wenn sie damit ja
sagen es sind nicht ihre Gedanken aber
dann sind es trotzdem ihre Worte warum
verwenden Sie diese Formulierungen
ich kann Ihnen nur sagen wenn ich
Staatsanwalt bin ja ich bin von der
Ausbildung her Jurist und ich werfe
jemanden Rassismus vor bin ich nicht als
Staatsanwalt der Rassist sondern ich bin
der Ankläger und denjenigen die nicht
angeklagt habe wegen Rassismus ist
derjenige der sich rechtfertigen muss
was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe
angeklagt ich habe in einem Artikel und
in einem Interview habe ich vorgeworfen
links grüner Seite zumindest in
Strömungen einen Rassismus zu dulden
oder zu fördern und damit das ist mein
Anspruch muss ich die Politik
auseinandersetzen weil ich das für ein
berechtigten Vorwurf halten sie bekommen
ja auch Gegenwind von ihrer früheren
Behörde der aktuelle
Verfassungsschutzpräsident halten wann
grenzt sich scharf von ihnen ab er
attestiert in eine gefährliche
Radikalisierung lässt sie das kalt
ich habe das aufmerksam zu Kenntnis
genommen und ich halte es für ungehörig
dass er sich über meine Person geäußert
hat ohne jegliche Belege vorzulegen ich
bin gerne bereit mit ihm wie mit vielen
anderen Kritikern zu sprechen wenn es
über pauschalisierte Vorwürfe hinausgeht
und man mir konkret nachweisen kann wo
ich Fehler gemacht habe oder wo ich mich
inkorrekt Verhalten habe wenn man mir
das nachweisen kann bin ich der Letzte
der zögern würde sich dafür zu
entschuldigen aber ich gehe davon aus
dass man mir dies nicht nachweisen wird
weil man es nicht nachweisen kann
Hans-Georg Maaßen vielen Dank für das
heutige Gespräch und ja dieser Streit
wird noch ein paar Tage weitergehen
vielen Dank nach Berlin sehr gerne